in his response former President Barack
Obama blamed public officials for not
putting stronger gun limits in place mr.
Obama also said in a statement quote we
should soundly reject the mouths of any
of our leaders that normalizes racist
sentiments he did not mention President
Trump by names former President Bill
Clinton echoed the call for new gun laws
ed O'Keefe is covering the road to 2020
and as far as the Democratic candidates
are concerned what are they saying well
Dana what aren't they saying and they're
saying it because there's strong
national support for changes in gun laws
like expanding background checks and
because polling shows the Democrats
especially are always concerned about
the issue of gun control it's
irresponsible that we don't take action
20:20 presidential candidates have been
blanketing the airwaves since the
shootings in Texas and Ohio there's a
better path that we can go down in this
country I mean it's there it is
unspeakable and it's hard to even talk
about it
but if they win the White House how
would the candidates curb gun violence
there are some differences in the
details but Democratic contenders
generally support expanding the National
gun background check system renewing a
ban on military-style assault weapons
and passing red flag laws to temporarily
block people from buying a gun if
they're considered an imminent risk to
themselves or to others how exactly a
ban on assault weapons would work is
unclear according to a 2018 report by
the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco Firearms
and Explosives there are roughly six
hundred thirty eight thousand machine
guns in circulation in the US which
includes assault rifles former housing
secretary who Leon Castro former
congressman Bill o'roarke
and former Vice President Joe Biden
support a national assault weapons
buyback program we can in fact make a
major effort to get them off the street
and out of the possession of people New
Jersey Senator Cory Booker is among
those pushing for national gun licensing
he licensed in America by the - excuse
me to drive a car
usually the license to buy a gun and to
possess it and Minnesota senator Amy
Klobuchar and others want to close the
so-called boyfriend loophole that
activists say allow people who've
stalked abused or assaulted someone to
still buy firearms in Congress some
Republicans are now saying they're
willing to
work with Democrats to implement those
red flag laws in recent days Democrats
have been calling on Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell to recall the
Senate and take up gun control
legislation he isn't planning on doing
that but in a statement yesterday said
Senate Republicans are quote prepared to
do our part to engage in bipartisan
discussions of potential solutions to
help protect our communities without
infringing on Americans constitutional
rights tarika IDI thank you once again
we wait to see what happens